well christmas has come and gone and for
that that means in addition to the
collection yes I do have a sonic
screwdriver collection yes I
traditionally I get an addition to it
every Christmas and the latest one that
I got is the twelfth doctor sonic
screwdriver so I'm gonna do something
that I haven't done before don't know if
I'll ever do it again I'm I'm basically
gonna give a toy or who you of the
twelfth doctor sonic screwdriver now
there's there's a lot I really like
about this thing and there's a few
things that I don't but you know what
let's start with the positive this is
very simple it's very streamlined now a
lot of the sonic screwdrivers they tend
to run the gamut between almost too
simple or too complicated so like for
example the war doctor the fourth doctor
the third doctor they all have the same
basic template you just pull it down and
it just does one of a couple of noises
some of the other ones though like River
Song sonic screwdriver was actually the
first one I ever got the tenth doctors
the eleventh a little bit and certainly
the the custom one that is this thing
way over complicated in a number of
areas um in terms of like what you have
to do to get to all the options out of
it all the things that it can do they
could be more she designed this is
nicely streamlined it is one button and
it is directional you press it up or you
pull it down which is two colors which
the only other one that is two colors at
this point is river songs a screwdriver
which has a red and blue setting that
one though you have to like pull a panel
off Flicka sweat you can't this one it's
it's that simple
which direction changed it I love that
it's also got four different sound
options now a lot of the ones with sound
options is one of two things it's either
cycling through different ones every
time you hit the activation button or in
the case of like that custom one I
showed you a minute ago it has a number
The Ramones but you have to press the
button different you have to light it
goes up to seven like you hit it once
it's one thing twice is another than
three times then four to end that's a
little cumbersome this it basically
combines everything into something nice
streamlined so you saw the basics now
two times up two times down and so in
addition to two colors which I love
I like those as well and I like I just
like the feel of these and how they just
feel that well first of all if you
hadn't noticed slightly different sound
on the red and green which I also like
that's a cool thing didn't have to do it
but they did
but there's something sort of tranquil
about that one and there's something at
least to my ear slightly ominous about
that one between the way it flashes and
the sound and I really like that I love
I just I loved the options that they've
put on this I love the way it's
implemented really the only complaints I
have I have nothing to do with the toy
the toy as far as I'm concerned is
basically a five-star product the only
companies that I have have to do with
complaints about just the design of the
screwdriver and that's not the fault of
the toy that's the fault of the show and
it somehow manages to be both oddly
blocky and yet strangely over-designed
usually when you would you think you get
something this chunky this basically
does that because I mean it's you know
it's just this oddly square thing and
yet it's got you know all these little
bits here that are clamp on it seems
like that's clamping holding it down
it's got these down here it's got this
that you know it doesn't actually move
but you get the feel that you know
that's intended to rotate so those are
these nits and knobs and these bits and
it seems like it but it seems like these
are unnecessary to me just from a design
standpoint the clamson
up here that's kind of okay and the
overall just sort of blockiness I'm not
a huge fan of I like the rounded shape
as a general rule but again those are
complaints about the design of the prop
not the toy just as a toy this
just with the streamline of it and Howie
see the different options are and you
know for options especially career
example as some of the other ones do
doesn't sound like a lot but when
they're that varied for is a great
number and how easily you switch between
them this basically in terms of
functionality this is my new favorite I
don't know if visually in terms of
looking at it it can ever be my favorite
overall but definitely in terms of the
way it works new favorite screwdriver
absolutely so if you are a doctor who
lover get it if you like the twelfth
doctor get it if you're uh if you are
like me and you are a sonic screwdriver
completest this will be one of your
favorites cuz as I have gotten more of
them I've noticed certain repetitions
and certain design choices like I
mentioned war doctor three for basically
is the same one just with a slightly
different casing they all activate the
same way the same sound so getting
something this different from the others
was absolutely one of the highlights of
my Christmas so if you have been
wondering if this one is worth getting
if you like this kind of stuff at all
get it get it right away cuz this is
this is awesome and this was one of the
things that made this a pretty good
Christmas for me so that's my thoughts
on this thing again no idea if I'll do
this sort of thing again I don't I'd
pick up this kind of stuff for myself
incredibly frequently so I don't know if
or when I'll ever do something like this
again but I wanted to give it a try
and just talk about this thing because
like I said or really liked it so um
hope you found that interesting guys uh
you know you have any thoughts on this
what sonic screwdrivers do you have
what's your favorite sonic screwdriver
whether you know it's a toy prop or
whether it's just aesthetically looking
at them on the show what's your favorite
whatever it is drop something down in
the comments and let's talk about it
don't forget to Like subscribe
turn on some notifications so you know
when I've gotten new videos up check me
out on Twitter our council of geeks give
a listen to the council of geeks
podcasts available on iTunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned